- Ok now this is a work
in progress.
- Unless of course you like it.
- Yeah if you like it, it can be
the finished product.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- That's great.
(music)
- We're gonna put together the
best friggin ad you ever seen.
- Yeah or else we'll die trying.
- Boom!
- Oh no, my friend's dead.
- You know what's cool?
Yes!
- Being your ding dong self.
- Yes!
- Let's party!
- Commercials have the power to
change the world.
- Hey buddy! Boner!
(slap)
- Oh!
- Your husband's a psycho!
- Oh wow.
- I wouldn't jerk that guy off
with Freddy Kreuger's hand.
- Was that a joke?
- Yeah.
- You've made an old lady very
very drunk.
- Chrissy, you're a bad person.
- Go eat pineapples you
fat-head.
- Shut up.
- Alright let's get down to
brass tacks. Who's shitting his
pants?
- It's Tim's jacket.
- Shut up.
- It stinks.
- Sell me this pencil.
- Uh...
(mumbles)
- Pocket porgages. It's a little
pocket for  porgages.
- And maybe the baby
craps itself.
- Uh.
- I feel really good about that
one.
- Yeah, it was like our best
pitch in months man. It was
really good.
- It's a no.
- Goddamn it!
- You want to ride it again one
more time?
- Yeah one more time.
- One more time we'll do it
again.
- One more time and then we'll
come back up and do it another
time after that.